We are going to compare the behavior of 3
different cache configurations on a benchmark
program to better understand the impact of
the cache configuration on the performance
of the benchmark.
The first cache we will consider is a 64-line
direct mapped cache.
The second is a 2-way set associative cache
that uses the LRU, or least recently used,
replacement strategy, and has a total of 64
lines.
The third is a 4-way set associative cache
that uses the LRU replacement strategy, and
also has a total of 64 lines.
Note that all three caches have the same capacity
in that they can store a total of 64 words
of data.
In a direct mapped cache any particular memory
address maps to exactly one line in the cache.
Let's assume that our data is 32 bits, or
4 bytes wide.
This means that consecutive addresses are
4 bytes apart, so we treat the bottom two
address bits as always being 00 so that our
address is on a data word boundary.
Next, we want to determine which cache line
this particular address maps to.
Since there are 64 lines in this cache, we
need 6 bits to select one of the 64 lines.
These 6 bits are called the index.
In this example, the index is 000011, so this
particular address maps to line 3 of the cache.
The data that gets stored in the cache is
the tag portion of the address of the line
plus the 32 bits of data.
The tag is used for comparison when checking
if a particular address is in the cache or
not.
It uniquely identifies the particular memory
address.
In addition, each cache line has a valid bit
that lets you know whether the data in the
cache is currently valid or not.
This is important upon startup because without
this bit there is no way to know whether the
data in the cache is garbage or real data.
In a 2-way set associative cache, the cache
is divided into 2 sets each with half the
number of lines.
So we have two sets with 32 lines each.
Since there are only 32 lines, we now only
need a 5 bit index to select the line.
However, any given index can map to two distinct
locations, one in each set.
This also means that when the tag comparisons
are done, two comparisons are required, one
per set.
In a 4-way set associative cache, the cache
is divided into 4 sets each with 16 lines.
The width of the index is now 4 bits to select
the cache line.
Here, selecting a line identifies one of 4
words as possible locations for reading or
writing the associated data.
This also implies that 4 tags need to be compared
when trying to read from the cache to determine
if the desired address is stored in the cache
or not.
The test program begins by defining a few
constants, J, A, B, and N.
J specifies the address where the program
lives.
A is the starting address of data region 1,
and B is the starting address of data reppose that we want to achieve an average
read access time of 1.1 cycles.
What is the minimum hit ratio required to
achieve this average access time over many
reads?
We know that average access time = (hit time
* hit rate) + (miss time * miss rate).
If we call 'a' our hit rate, then our miss
rate is (1-a).
So our desired average access time of 1.1
must equal 1 * a plus 9 * (1-a).
This reduces to 1.1 = 9-8a, which means that
8a = 7.9 or a = 7.9/8.
So to achieve a 1.1 cycle average access time
our hit rate must be at least 7.9/8.
We are provided with this benchmark program
for testing our 2-way set associative cache.
The cache is initially empty before execution
begins.
In other words, all the valid bits of the
cache are 0.
Assuming that an LRU, or least recently used,
replacement strategy is used, we would like
to determine the approximate cache hit ratio
for this program.
Let's begin by understanding what this benchmark
does.
The program begins at address 0.
It first performs some initialization of registers
using three CMOVE operations.
The first, initializes R0 to hold source which
is the address in memory where our data will
be stored.
The second initializes R1 to 0, and the third
initializes R2 to 0x1000 which is the number
of words that this benchmark will work with.
We then enter the loop which is shown in the
yellow rectangle.
The loop loads the first element of our data
from location source + 0 into register R3.
It then increments R0 to point to the next
piece of data.
Since our data is 32 bits wide, this requires
the addition of the constant 4 representing
the number of bytes between consecutive data
words.
It then takes the value that was just loaded
and adds it to R1 which holds a running sum
of all the data seen so far.
R2 is then decremented by 1 to indicate that
we have one fewer piece of data to handle.
Finally, as long as R2 is not equal to 0 it
repeats the loop.
At the very end of the benchmark the final
sum is stored at address source, and the program
halts.
When trying to determine the approximate hit
ratio, the instructions that occur only once
because they live outside of the loop can
basically be ignored.
So looking only at what happens over and over
again in the loop, each time through the loop,
we have 5 instruction fetches and one data
fetch.
The first time through the loop, we miss on
the instruction fetches and then bring them
into the cache.
We also miss on the data load from address
0x100.
When this data is brought into the cache,
instead of replacing the recently loaded instructions,
it loads the data into the 2nd set of the
cache.
The loop is then repeated.
This time through the loop, all the instruction
fetches result in hits.
However, the data that we now need is a new
piece of data so that will result in a cache
miss and once again load the new data word
into the 2nd set of the cache.
This behavior then repeats itself every time
through the loop.
Since the loop is executed many times, we
can also ignore the initial instruction fetches
on the first iteration of the loop.
So in steady state, we get 5 instruction cache
hits, and 1 data cache miss every time through
the loop.
This means that our approximate hit ratio
is 5/6.
The last question we want to consider is what
is stored in the cache after execution of
this benchmark is completed.
As we saw earlier, because we have a 2-way
set associative cache, the instructions and
data don't conflict with each other because
they can each go in a separate set.
We want to determine which instruction and
which piece of data will end up in line 4
of the cache after execution is completed.
We'll begin by identifying the mapping of
instructions to cache lines.
Since our program begins at address 0, the
first CMOVE instruction is at address 0, and
it's index is equal to 0b000, or 0 in binary.
This means that it will map to cache line
0.
Since at this point, nothing is in the cache,
it will be loaded into line 0 of set A.
In a similar manner the next 2 CMOVE instructions
and the LD instruction will be loaded into
lines 1-3 of set A.
At this point, we begin loading data.
Since the cache is 2-way set associative,
the data will be loaded into set B instead
of removing the instructions that were loaded
into set A.
The instructions that are outside the loop
will end up getting taken out of set A in
favor of loading a data item into those cache
locations, but the instructions that make
up the loop will not be displaced because
every time something maps to cache lines 3-7,
the least recently used location will correspond
to a data value not to the instructions which
are used over and over again.
This means that at the end of execution of
the benchmark, the instruction that will be
in line 4 of the cache is the ADDC instruction
from address 0x10 of the program.
The loop instructions which will remain in
the cache are shown here.
Now let's consider what happens to the data
used in this benchmark.
We expect the loop instructions to remain
in lines 3-7 of set A of the cache.
The data will use all of set B plus locations
0-2 of set A as needed.
The data begins at address 0x100.
The index portion of address 0x100 is 0b000
so this data element maps to cache line 0.
Since the least recently used set for line
0 is set B, it will go into set B leaving
the instructions in tact in set A.
The next data element is at address 0x104.
Since the bottom two bits are used for word
alignment, the index portion of this address
is 0b001, so this data element maps to line
1 of set B, and so on through element 0x7.
Data element 0x8 is at address 0x120.
The index portion of this address is once
again 0b000.
So this element maps to cache line 0 just
like element 0x0 did.
However, at this point line 0 of set B was
accessed more recently than line 0 of set
A, so the CMOVE instruction which is executed
only once will get replaced by a data element
that maps to line 0.
As we mentioned earlier, all the instructions
in the loop will not be displaced because
they are accessed over and over again so they
never end up being the least recently used
item in a cache line.
After executing the loop 16 times meaning
that data elements 0 through 0xF have been
accessed, the cache will look like this.
Note that the loop instructions continue in
their original location in the cache.
The state of the cache continues to look like
this with more recently accessed data elements
replacing the earlier data elements.
Since there are 0x1000 elements of data, this
continues until just before address 0x4100.
The last element is actually located 1 word
before that at address 0x40FC.
The last 8 elements of the data and their
mapping to cache lines is shown here.
The data element that ends up in line 4 of
the cache, when the benchmark is done executing,
is element 0x0FFC of the data which comes
from address 0x40F0.BNE(R0,
R) instruction which is already in the cache
at line 5.
From then on the remaining data accesses all
result in hits.
At this point we have completed the inner
loop and proceed to the remaining instructions
in the outer loop.
These instructions are the second SUBC and
the second BNE instructions.
These correspond to the data that is in lines
6 and 7 of the cache thus resulting in hits.
The loop then repeats itself 1000 times but
each time through all the instructions and
all the data is in the cache so they all result
in hits.
So the total number of misses that we get
when executing this benchmark on a direct
mapped cache is 16.
These are known as compulsory misses which
are misses that occur when you are first loading
the data into your cache.
Recall that the direct mapped cache has one
set of 64 lines in the cache.
The 2-way set associative has 2 sets of 32
lines each, and the 4-way set associative
has 4 sets of 16 lines each.
Since only 16 lines are required to fit all
the instructions and data associated with
this benchmark, this means that effectively,
only one set will be used in the set associative
caches, and because even in the 4-way set
associative cache there are 16 lines, that
means that once the data is loaded into the
cache it does not need to be replaced with
other data so after the first miss per line,
the remaining accesses in the entire benchmark
will be hits.
So the total number of misses in the 2-way
and 4-way set associative caches is also 16.